beisetzung für einen dessen schicksal
ein ganzes land bewegt george floyd soll
seine letzte ruhe finden amerika
diskutiert ob seine polizeibehörden
komplett neu aufgestellt werden müssen
großdemonstrationen in zeiten von corona
kann das gehen kundgebungen mit abstand
und umstrittene quarantäne regel in
großbritannien jeder der ins land kommt
muss ab heute für 14 tage in isolation
die nachrichten nicht da das heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
montag wir geben ihnen den überblick in
den kommenden zwanzig minuten guten
abend dazu und auch ann kristin otto die
den sport beisteuert george wright wurde
46 jahre alt seien tot als ihn ein
polizist minuten lang auf den boden
drückte hat nicht nur die menschen in
den usa erschüttert jetzt im moment
laufen die trauerfeier für ihn in
houston texas seiner heimatstadt in
einem goldenen sarg ist floyd in einer
kirche aufgebahrt die menschen der stadt
können ihnen dort die letzte ehre
erweisen
viele sind gekommen um abschied zu
nehmen bevor er morgen beigesetzt wird
george wright der name steht
mittlerweile für die opfer von rassismus
und polizeigewalt generell und in seinem
namen fordert hunderttausende echte
konsequenzen in minneapolis tvo floyd
starb soll die komplette polizei ganz
neu organisiert werden indes trans kürzt
der polizei das budget die band the
police das ist der neue schlachtruf der
demonstranten
landauf landab fordern sie eine
umfassende polizeireform erste städte
reagieren so will do york city das
budget der polizeibehörde kürzen und das
geld stattdessen in jugend- und
sozialarbeit stecken
wir haben eine starke polizei wir können
uns erlauben dort geld abzuziehen und es
in jugendprogramme zu stecken
gleichzeitig können wir die new yorker
schützen dies ist präventiv abgeordnete
und senatoren der demokraten knien im
kongress mit einer gesetzesinitiative
wollen sie den umstrittenen
ein würgegriff landesweit verbieten und
fehlverhalten von polizisten schneller
ahnten polizeibrutalität ist das
herzzerreißende zeichen eines systems
von ungleichheit zwischen den ethnien
wahre gerechtigkeit kann nur mit um
verschieden handeln erreicht werden dass
gehen wir heute an präsident rammten die
demokraten verrückt recht und ordnung
twittert er der polizei dürfe kein geld
entzogen werden der polizist unterdessen
knie george floyd verstarb wird heute
dem haftrichter vorgeführt der stadtrat
in minneapolis beschloss derweil die
polizeibehörde der stadt ganz neu zu
begründen
wir müssen die schlechte beziehung
zwischen unserer stadt und der polizei
beenden polizeiarbeit wie wir sie kennen
darf es nicht geben
am nachmittag trauerfeier für george
floyd in houston wo er aufwuchs sein tod
hat viel in bewegung gesetzt was er
jedoch verändern wird ist unklar
bringen wir unseren usa korrespondenten
mit dazu elmar guten abend manche
glauben nicht mehr daran dass polizei so
wie sie ist das problem in den griff
bekommt was macht us polizeibehörden
denn so anfällig für übergriffe und
rassismus es gibt glaube ich zwei gründe
dafür der eine grund ist die
militarisierung der polizei das heißt
man hat eine ausrüstung man hat waffen
man hat schutzkleidung die das gefühl
vermitteln es wäre in ordnung exzessive
gewalt anzuwenden da wird dann jede
begegnung mit irgendjemandem mit
ermöglichen delinquenten hochstilisiert
zu einer art kampf auf leben und tod das
ist das eine problem aber das viel
größere ist die fehlende
rechenschaftspflicht man kann noch so
viele regeln machen man kann auch noch
so viele neue bessere regeln machen wenn
die regelbrecher als wie diese regeln
brechen nicht zur verantwortung gezogen
werden
dann hilft es nichts und das ist ein
phänomen das sehen wir im ganzen land
dass starke polizeigewerkschaften das
seilschaften regelrecht in einigen
städten vorhanden sind die verhindern
dass beamte die die regeln brechen dann
auch tatsächlich zur verantwortung
gezogen werden
und das ist der grund weshalb einige
sagen wir müssen die polizei abteilungen
abschaffen um sie ganz neu wieder
aufzubauen also nicht gar keine polizei
sondern man muss sie ersetzen durch eine
polizei die wirklich auch
rechenschaftspflichtig ist einmal vielen
dank für diese hintergrundinformationen
live aus washington nicht nur in den usa
rund um den globus hören die
protestkundgebungen nicht auf das hier
ist brasilien wo es zehntausende waren
gegen polizeigewalt und rassismus auf
den straßen bristol england hier entlädt
sich der zorn von demonstranten an der
statue eines politikers aus dem 17ten
jahrhundert der am sklavenhandel
beteiligt war und auch in deutschland
gehen die menschen auf die strassen aus
wut über alltäglichen rassismus den es
auch bei uns gibt mehr als 100.000 waren
es am wochenende in verschiedenen
städten gucken wir uns das mal an
münchen 25.000 menschen 20.000 in
hamburg 15.000 in leipzig meist deutlich
mehr teilnehmer als erwartet und
deutlich weniger platz
da stellt sich wie generell bei großen
kundgebungen die frage wie hoch ist die
gefahr dass sich bei dieser art von
protest das corona virus verbreitet eine
frage die auch in der politik diskutiert
wird thomas reichhardt berichtet stopp
killing aus hört auf uns zu töten
es sind mehr viel mehr als ursprünglich
angemeldet die am wochenende gegen das
verbrechen an george floyd protestieren
und ein zeichen setzen wollen gegen
rassismus in deutschland
am tag danach loben fast alle in der
politik die demonstration und fast alle
sind besorgt wie nah sich die menschen
dabei in corona zeiten kamen die die auf
die straße gegangen sind sie zeigen an
besonderen bürgersinn aber dieser bürger
sind muss eben auch mit blick auf
bewohner gelten
auf dem berliner alexanderplatz tragen
die meisten mundschutz nicht eingehalten
aber werden ganz offensichtlich die
abstandsregeln ähnlich in münchen die
polizei dort schreitet nicht ein weil
das zitat durch die erheblichen
teilnehmerzahlen und die erwartbaren
gruppendynamischen effekte mit blick auf
die verhältnismäßigkeit nicht geboten
gewesen sei heißt die polizei wollte
auseinandersetzungen vermeiden
die afg sieht darin ein gegensatz zu den
polizeieinsätzen bei anti corona demos
das
verletzt das grundrecht auf
demonstration das gilt für alle gleich
für die antirassismus demonstration
genauso wie für die anti corona
demonstration zwei lamas bedeutet eine
verletzung des wesentlichen grundrecht
für die demokratie das wir haben und das
ist das demonstrationsrecht welches
recht aber ist wichtiger dass auf
protest oder jenes auf schutz vor dem
virus
ich kann an dieser stelle nochmal
deutlich machen dass das recht auf
demonstration und die absolut nach wie
vor notwendigen hygieneregeln nicht in
widerspruch stehen sondern dass man auf
demonstrationen entsprechende hygiene
regeln auch einhalten muss berlin
diskutiert die abwägung von der rechten
die entscheidung aber was geht und was
nicht die müssen am ende wieder
ordnungsämter und polizei treffen
in deutschland ist die zahl der
täglichen corona neuinfektionen im
moment weiter niedrig im schnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 330 menschen neu angesteckt und
stand vor einer halben stunde hat die
johns hopkins universität knapp 186.000
infizierte registriert davon gelten fast
170.000 als genesen 8690 menschen sind
in verbindung mit dem virus gestorben
weitere zahlen und erklärungen dazu
finden sie in der zdf- heute- erb und
dort gibt es auch eine analyse welche
jobs besonders von der krise betroffen
sind
es ist keine leichte entscheidung ob
nämlich dass corona risiko inzwischen so
niedrig ist dass die grundschulen wieder
für alle öffnen können mit ganz normalem
unterricht mit hygienevorschriften aber
ohne mindestabstand in den klassenräumen
schleswig holstein hat diese
entscheidung so getroffen heute morgen
ging es wieder los und hermann beantwort
dabei erst einmal aufstellen mit
mundschutz auf dem schulhof getrennt
nach klassen nacheinander geht es dann
in verschiedene eingänge des gebäudes
tech und schule in kiel russee es geht
wieder los für alle 286 schüler auch für
jene in der 3b und jetzt immer wieder
die ganze klasse und kann auch zusammen
unterricht machen und so und das ist
schön
ich muss rein gehen meine jacke darf ich
aufheben magath robe und dann muss ich
mich einem hände waschen und dann
absetzen wie der tägliche unterricht dem
gewohnten klassenverband und doch ist
wegen krone auflage vieles anders
händewaschen etwas pflicht erst dann
geht es an die plätze ohne mundschutz im
klassenraum wissen die abstände nun
nicht mehr streng eingehalten werden
es sei wichtig dass jetzt wo den großen
ferien die kompletten klassen wieder
zusammenkommen sagt die zuständige
ministerin ja sind inzwischen der
auffassung bei dem extrem niedrigen
pandemie geschehene schleswig holstein
dass eine weitere schließung der
grundschulen nicht mehr vertretbar ist
die 26 kinder hier wurden von ihrer
lehrerin in den vergangenen tagen auf
den neustart vorbereitet zurück zu einer
art normalbetrieb das gehe viel zu
schnell sagen kritiker der
gesundheitsschutz viele kollegen und
kollegen ist nicht gewahrt und auch für
die schülerinnen und schüler und die
eltern ist natürlich die gefahr einer
ansteckung weiterhin gegeben auch wenn
die fallzahlen im moment niedrig sind in
der 3b in kiel russee starten sie heute
erst mal mit einer stunde deutsch und in
dreieinhalb wochen beginnen schon die
sommerferien
die britische regierung gibt der welt
beim thema corona im moment rätsel auf
erst dauerte es wochen bis premier boris
johnson auf die bedrohung reagiert
jetzt da die regierungen ringsherum
verbote lockern setzt johnson eine neue
quarantäne pflicht in kraft jeder der
ein reist wird erst einmal zwei wochen
isoliert
die britische wirtschaft fürchtet den
kollaps fakt ist dass großbritannien das
land mit den meisten corona toten in
europa ist mehr als 48.000 menschen sagt
die staatliche statistikbehörde aus
london andreas stamm
politische turbulenzen gegenwind in der
korona krise für die britische regierung
fast schon alltag ganz europa hebt
reisebeschränkungen allmählich auf doch
wer nach großbritannien ein reist mit
wenigen ausnahmen muss nun in eine
zweiwöchige strenge häusliche quarantäne
selbst in der regierungspartei regiert
kopfschütteln die gedanklichen
verrenkungen in dieser politik leuchtet
mir nicht ein wenn eine quarantäne nötig
ist warum kam sie nicht viel früher auch
die britische tourismusindustrie
versteht die welt nicht mehr
die branche droht bis zu 60 prozent
aller jobs streichen zu müssen mehrere
fluggesellschaften gehen nun vor gericht
das ganze ist nur ein politischer trick
um das komplette versagen der regierung
in der korona krise zu vertuschen es
gibt keine strategie um diese krise
meistern zu können so ist großbritannien
zum kranken mann europas geworden
die regierung beharrt darauf die
quarantäne sei effektiver
gesundheitsschutz die ersten betroffenen
reagieren am morgen mit gemischten
gefühlen
es kann nun angenehm sein aber ich finde
es okay ich komme ja in ein land mit
hoher infektionsrate sind germany in
deutschland ist die infektionsrate
niedriger hier wird man doch eher
angesteckt das macht doch keinen sinn
der unmut zeigt wirkung erst die ideen
die regelung aufzuweichen kursieren eine
liste von staaten mit niedrigen
infektionszahlen etwa könnte
tourismusindustrie und den urlaub von
millionen briten retten doch bis dahin
gilt wer einreist egal ob ausländer oder
urlaubsrückkehrer muss erstmal in
quarantäne
gute nachrichten in der weltweiten
corona krise kommen aus neuseeland das
land hat sich für virus frei erklärt
alle einschränkungen sollen jetzt
vorerst aufgehoben werden sagt
regierungschefin jobcenter denn der
letzte coup 19 patient zeige seit 48
stunden keine symptome mehr und sei
genesen
jörn lobte ihre landsleute sie hätten
den beispielloser weise zusammen
gehalten um das virus zu brechen
die strikten grenzkontrollen will das
land beibehalten
zurück nach deutschland und dem
aktuellen fall von kindesmissbrauch in
münster werden jetzt viele fragen
gestellt vor allem an die behörden das
jugendamt etwa hätte man verhindern
können dass mindestens drei kinder zu
opfern wurden schließlich war der
mutmaßliche haupttäter einschlägig
vorbestraft sieben verdächtige sitzen
zurzeit in haft
ihnen wird unter anderem schwerer
sexueller missbrauch vorgeworfen
dort bewerber berichtet auch heute durch
suchen spezialisten die kleingarten
laube in münster hier soll der 27
jährige auch seinen zehnjährigen ziese
und missbraucht haben
dabei war die familie dem jugendamt
bekannt der mann einschlägig vorbestraft
2018 stieß die polizei erneut auf bilder
die ihm zuzuordnen waren
die auswertung dauert der man lieber
freiem fuß dieser neue fall von
mehrfachen schweren sexuellen missbrauch
von kindern in münster habe nicht nur in
münster sondern ja auch in anderen
teilen der republik macht mich wieder
mal fassungslos es wird eine aufgabe
sein die uns noch lange lange zeit
beschäftigt und ich wette münster ist
nicht die nicht das ende
auch in münster wird nun die frage nach
der verantwortung der behörden gestellt
ähnlich wie im missbrauchsfall möchte
auch dort war das jugendamt involviert
aufklärung wird gefordert
es gibt in nordrhein westfalen einen
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
und ich hoffe dass der jetzt einen
untersuchungsauftrag erweitert und hier
auch die lupe genaue ansetzung zu
schauen wo fehler begangen wurden die
polizei ist nach lichte tatsächlich
wachsamer in nordrhein westfalen wurde
die zahl der ermittler
seither vervierfacht das alleine aber
reiche nicht heißt es
der gesetzgeber muss tatsächlich noch
einmal klar
machen dass es nicht sein kann wenn man
mehrere tausend missbrauchsdarstellungen
handelt das dann noch bewährungsstrafen
möglich sind drastische strafen für
täter und mittäter bei sexuellem
missbrauch die politik diskutiert
darüber nach den neuen fällen in münster
gegen einen mutmaßlichen
rechtsextremisten aus hildesheim wird
wegen einer terrordrohung gegen muslime
ermittelt der mann wurde festgenommen
nachdem er in einem internet chat einen
anschlag mit mehreren toten angekündigt
hatte
dabei bezog er sich auf den attentäter
von christchurch in neuseeland
in der wohnung des 21-jährigen wurden
waffen und dateien mit rechtsradikalen
inhalten gefunden
jetzt steht es fest der frühere audi
chef rupert stadler muss sich vor
gericht für den diesel skandal
verantworten
das münchner landgericht hat die anklage
jetzt zugelassen stadler werden betrug
und weitere delikte vorgeworfen die
staatsanwaltschaft sagt er habe die
diesel autos weiterverkauft auch nachdem
er von den abgas manipulationen erfahren
hatte
jürgen wollmann berichtet
rupert stadler am scheideweg mai 2018
sein letzter auftritt als
vorstandsvorsitzender auf einer audi
hauptversammlung als bisher einziger
vorstandschef eines großen deutschen
autobauers muss er sich nun vor gericht
verantworten
das landgericht münchen zwei hat die
sogenannte audi anklage im wesentlichen
unverändert zur hauptverhandlung
zugelassen und der prozess wird am 30
september 2020 beginnen
über zehn jahre vorstandsvorsitzender
von audi seit 2015 soll er von den abgas
manipulationen gewusst haben aber den
verkauf der autos nicht verhindert haben
rupert stadler gab sich als aufklärer
die diesel krise wo ich sage ich hier
wir kommen denn noch in der aufarbeitung
gut voran arbeiten unermüdlich an einer
lückenlosen aufklärung
kurz darauf kam rupert stadler vier
monate in untersuchungshaft wegen
verdunklungsgefahr
es wird ein umfangreicher prozess 176
verhandlungstage sind angesetzt
ob rupert stadler wegen betruges
verurteilt wird hängt vor allem davon ab
ob im vorsatz nachgewiesen werden kann
dh entscheidend ist ob er wusste dass
100.000 audis eine illegale software
eingebaut ist und er den verkauf dennoch
nicht stoppte
robert stadler hat die vorwürfe
abgestritten der skandal hat audi bisher
mehr als drei milliarden euro gekostet
die anklage gegen martin winterkorn dem
ehemaligen chef des vw konzerns zu dem
audi gehört hat das gericht in
braunschweig noch nicht zugelassen so
jetzt bin ich gespannt auf das neueste
vom sport christin das wirst du ich habe
zwei themen zuerst basketball zweiter
spieltag in der finalrunde um die
deutsche meisterschaft titelverteidiger
bayern münchen stand in der gruppe a
bereits unter druck nach der
auftaktniederlage gegen ulm gegen
crailsheim dominierten aber die bayern
das geschehen
keiner der beiden mannschaften hatte
nach den auftaktniederlagen etwas zu
verschenken die münchner zu beginn
allerdings noch mit unkonzentriertheiten
die crailsheim eiskalt nutzen kann
dann aber kommen die münchner zur freude
von bayern ikone uli hoeneß besser ins
spiel
zwischenzeitlich ein 15 tonnen abschnitt
für den titelverteidiger der seine
führung immer klarer aus bauschheim
wehrt sich nach kräften topskorer
erreger kann aber vor der pause nur zum
35 zu 51 verkürzen
münchens trainer oliver kostet muss sich
danach keine sorgen mehr um den sieg
machen besonders treffsicher matthias
liste mit 20 punkten bester werfer der
bayern
den schlusspunkt setzt die jailbreak mit
dem dreier zum deutlichen 110 79 erfolg
der titelverteidiger ist wieder drin im
rennen um die meisterschaft ja noch zum
fußball morgen und übermorgen abend die
halbfinals im dfb-pokal und dabei hofft
der erste fc saarbrücken auf eine
weitere überraschung mit einem sieg
gegen bayer leverkusen als erster
viertligist ins endspiel einzuziehen das
wären die im kleinen hermann neuberger
stadion in völklingen saarbrücken gegen
das grosse leverkusen gewinnen
trotz fehlender spielpraxis saison
abbruch in der regionalliga und ohne
ihre fans das spiel muss erst gespielt
werden und wir uns sicherlich nicht
einfach ergeben das ist ein halbfinale
wenn man da steht dann will man
natürlich auch ins finale doch im
halbfinale wartet auf die
überraschungsmannschaft leverkusen
immerhin 15 der bundesligatabelle
eingespielt und fast in bestbesetzung in
quarantäne hotel am samstag hatte das
team saarbrücken deren zwei zu 4
niederlage gegen die bayern genau
beobachtet ich glaube nicht dass
leverkusen der größte gegner ist so wenn
die furcht und wenn wir das ablegen
können dann bin ich guten gut ist dass
uns die nächste sensation gelingt
außenseiter waren sie schon öfter in
dieser pokalsaison gegen köln und
düsseldorf hat auch geklappt auch wenn
der kleine den großen gucken wir mal
danke christin ja ein blick nach paris
lohnt immer heute ganz besonders denn
die rettung von notre dame geht in eine
entscheidende phase
in 40 metern höhe wollen die kletterer
die kathedrale endlich von ihrem alten
gerüsten befreien
keine leichte aufgabe es geht um 40.000
teile 200 tonnen stahl
viele der rohre verschmolzen miteinander
als notre dame im april letzten jahres
brannte das team hofft am ende des
sommers großen ziel wieder ein stückchen
näher zu sein
mit regen im süden und sonne im norden
geht es morgen durch den tag alle
details vom wetter gleich mit osten
telli um 21 uhr empfehle ich ihnen das
heute journal mit dem kollegen claus
kleber heute ist welttag des meeres und
die kollegen haben recherchiert wie viel
schutz bieten die schutzgebiete morgen
punkt 7 gibt
uns wieder für heute danke für ihr
großes interesse und ihnen allen einen
sehr angenehmen montagabend tschüss
ein schokolade und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter über norditalien hält sich
ein tiefer und bewegt sich kaum und
schaufelt hier feuchte luft aus dem
süden zu uns und so gibt es regen
bis etwa zur mitte deutschlands hin
ansonsten im norden bleibt es meist
trocken
schauen wir auf die nacht da gibt es im
emsland einige schauer und dem süden da
zieht es schon allmählich zu mehr wolken
deutlich kompakter und regen ansonsten
ist es trocken temperaturen sinken dabei
auf 5 grad in schleswig holstein und elf
grad zum beispiel am niederrhein
morgen dann besonders im norden viel
sonnenschein entlang der küsten wenige
wolken sonst weiter zu ermitteln ist es
kompakter bewirkt einzelne schauer sind
dabei ganz anders sieht es dann ganz im
süden aus hier sind die worten deutlich
dichter und dieser regen der wandert
allmählich richtung mitte temperaturen
dazu 23 grad im osten und 14 grad zb an
den alpen
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage da
gibt es weitere schauer noch vor allem
im süden am mittwoch nach norden ist es
trockener fronleichnam ist es schon im
westen trockner und im osten gibt es
mehr schauer und freitag wird deutlich
weniger ring geben und vor allem bis 29
grad waren damit ein schöner abend